und jetzt das heute journal mit einer
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend ihnen die pfeile
gehen nach unten und das ist
ausnahmsweise mal die richtige richtung
zumindest aus europäischer sicht
deutschlands abhängigkeit von russischem
öl hat sich binnen weniger wochen mehr
als halbiert so dass die bundesregierung
ein mögliches öl-embargo gegen russland
jetzt forciert stadt dabei auf der
bremse zu stehen das führt zu einigen
fragen gleich hier an dem
bundeswirtschafts- und
klimaminister robert habeck das führt
auch dazu dass andere eu staaten
plötzlich farbe bekennen müssen und
siehe da die einigkeit europas ist in
der realität deutlich weniger klar als
in den sonntagsreden der zuständigen
politiker florian hahn jetzt mit mehr
aus brüssel
am ende dieses roten teppich sollte
mittag in brüssel da will der deutsche
vizekanzler etwas optimismus verbreiten
europäische grundregeln frei nach robert
habeck
das ist europa bisher immer gelungen
sich zu einigen na ja fast immer läuft
es heute also wie fast immer oder wird
das hier die ausnahme
sondersitzung der eu energieminister es
geht um russland energie die kleinen
details und die großen fragen wie diese
welche weiteren sanktionen soll europa
beschließen auch ein embargo auf
russisches öl da teilt die runde sich in
drei lager lager nummer eins die
hardliner angeführt von polen dem land
dem gerade von russland der gashahn
abgedreht worden ist wir polen rufen
heute zu sofortigen sanktionen auf
russisches öl und gas auf das ist der
nächste absolut notwendige schritt der
im nächsten sanktionspaket enthalten
sein sollte und ich glaube dass wir bei
dem heutigen treffen diese solidarität
bekommen werden
sanktionen jetzt auch auf russisches gas
das hat keine aussicht auf erfolg zu
groß ist immer noch die abhängigkeit von
russland aber beim nächsten rohstoff
gibt es bewegung dem russischen vor
allem weil sich lager nummer zwei hier
bewegt die ehemals zögerlichen plötzlich
kann sich auch deutschland ein
öl-embargo vorstellen nicht sofort aber
früher als gedacht auch wenn es
schmerzhaft wird wir werden höhere
inflation höhere energiepreise und eine
belastung der wirtschaft haben und wir
sind als europäerinnen und europäer
bereit die zu tragen um der ukraine zu
helfen der deutsche schwenk lässt andere
folgen österreich ist bereit ein
ölembargo auch konsequent mitzutragen
wenn die kommission und die
mitgliedstaaten sich dafür entscheiden
doch sanktionen müssen in der eu
einstimmig beschlossen werden und hier
kommt lager nummer drei ins spiel
die gegner das lager ist deutlich
geschrumpft auf zwei die slowakei und
ungarn beide haben tatsächlich ein
problem eine hohe abhängigkeit von
russischem öl und dazu im falle ungarns
an den ministerpräsidenten der sich nach
seinem wahlsieg vor vier wochen ziemlich
weit aus dem fenster gelehnt hat
eins ist sicher wir werden keinem druck
nachgeben die sanktionen gegen russland
auf gas und öl auszuweiten denn das
würde die ungarische wirtschaft
zerstören läuft es beim öl embargo wie
immer in europa dann ließen sich ungarn
und die slowakei auch diesmal ins boot
holen zum beispiel durch eine großzügige
übergangsfrist aber noch ist die sache
nicht gelaufen
der bundeswirtschaftsminister ist aus
brüssel bei uns in der sendung guten
abend robert habeck
guten abend grüßen deutschland
unterstützt den importstopp von
russischem öl das ist die schlagzeile
deutschland treibt diesen importstopp
jetzt geradezu an wann wird denn kommen
die europäische kommission wird morgen
vorschläge für ein sechstes aktionspaket
vorliegen ich gehe davon aus und ich
nehme an so wird es auch kommen dass
dort auch vorschläge zur reduktion von
öl also ein öl-embargo enthalten sein
werden den will ich nicht vorgreifen
aber ich kann sagen dass wir das mein
haus in der vergangenheit hart dafür
gearbeitet hat dass deutschland diesen
weg mitgehen und frei machen kann und
soll es jedenfalls nicht mehr scheitern
erwarten sie dass es auch an niemandem
anderen in der eu scheitern wird
ich komme gerade aus dem
energieministerrat wo wir uns intensiv
ausgetauscht haben man muss einfach
anerkennen dass die versorgungssituation
für die länder sehr sehr unterschiedlich
ist auch deutschland hat ja vor zwei
monaten da hätte ich das also diese
ansage von heute noch nicht machen
können und hab sie ja auch nicht getan
die länder haben also eine
unterschiedliche versorgungssituation
das muss man anerkennen und insofern
darf man auch kein land komplett
überfordert alle bemühen sich nach
leibeskräften schritte zur reduktion zu
unternehmen aber auch für die anderen
länder gilt das was ich als motto
ausgegeben habe erste schritte gut
vorbereiten und sie dann tun und ich
nehme an entsprechend vorsichtig wird
die europäische kommission vorgehen alle
bemühen sich sagen sie aus ungarn hört
man wie man es nicht
ja ungern bemüht sich vielleicht von
allen ländern am wenigsten aber das
würde dann mit orlando von russischen
diesel am ende an ungarn scheitert
fragezeichen
die europäische gemeinschaft ist ja
geübt darin schlage kompromisse zu
finden also es geht ja darum die zahlung
nach russland deutlich zu reduzieren am
ende sozusagen auf null zu setzen und
darum geht es und das wird auch gelingen
mit einem klugen vorschlag welchen sinn
macht ein embargo wenn man sehr sehr
lange im vorfeld darüber diskutiert alle
sin abwägt und dann am ende noch nicht
so einen richtigen termin dafür nennen
kann welchen welchen eindruck kann so
ein embargo dann noch machen auf
vladimir putin
das wird es schon tun
die nennung eines termins ähnlich wie
bei kohle ist er ein signal dass sich
die verträge ändern werden dass die
verträge umgestellt werden und darum
geht es ja wenn ich das jetzt mal ein
bisschen flapsig formulieren darf ist es
gar nicht so entscheidend ob heute oder
in den nächsten tagen oder wochen die
umstellung erfolgt das geht ja darum
dass die perspektive der finanzierung
dass die einfach genommen wird und
insofern natürlich wenn man alles mit
dem knopfdruck erledigen wir erledigen
könnte wäre es irgendwie einfacher die
dinge sind aber nicht einfach sie sind
kompliziert trotzdem ist das signal wir
werden solange der krieg andauert und
solange die sanktion aufrechterhalten
werden eure verschiedene energien nicht
mehr kaufen extrem wichtig wird auch
gehört werden und wird entsprechende
konsequenzen nach sich ziehen die
abhängigkeit deutschlands von russischem
öl ist schon deutlich entspannter
deutlich stärker zurückgefahren als noch
vor ein paar wochen trotzdem haben sie
gesagt ohne russisches öl so von heute
auf morgen wird ist zitat robert habeck
rumpelig werden was heißt das ganz
konkret
das heißt dass wir das drittel dass wir
an deutscher ölproduktion aus russland
bekommen haben auf ein weiteres drittel
also auf zwölf prozent reduziert haben
in der abhängigkeit diese zwölf prozent
werden vor allem von der raffinerie
schwedt
in brandenburg raffiniert und die
versorgung den ostdeutschen raum und dem
großraum berlin im kern ehrlich gesagt
ganz genau wissen wir es gar nicht wohin
die lieferbeziehung gehen weil die
raffinerien betrieben wird von rosneft
also einem russischen staatskonzern und
die lassen uns nicht in ihre bücher
reinschauen deswegen gibt es da eine
gewisse unsicherheit was genau an
lieferketten da dran hängt aber das was
wir wissen bedeutet das wenn wir es
nicht schaffen sehr schnell die
versorgungssituation für die raffinerie
sicherzustellen oder den großraum aus
anderen quellen zu versorgen dass es
tatsächlich zu lieferausfällen und
entsprechend zu höheren preisen führen
kann also das muss man sich klarmachen
dass das was jetzt als
schritt und auch als leistung gefeiert
wird dass deutschland diesen schritt
mitgehen kann wird eine zumutung
bedeuten sollen niemand sagen er hätte
es nicht vorher gewusst wenn nachher die
preise nach oben geben das wird das wird
sehr sicher so kommen und das ist der
preis der getragen werden kann und
getragen werden muss allerdings bedeutet
dies nicht mehr dass die ganze
volkswirtschaft und kippt wie es gewesen
wäre wenn von heute auf morgen ein
drittel der produktion wegfallen würde
das haben wir überwunden aber wir werden
trotzdem eine härte spüren und die
menschen in den bezugs räumen vor der
lieferung von schwedt die werden sie
besonders spüren also insbesondere im
osten deutschlands aus dem großraum
berlin herr habeck die art wie sie
kommunizieren bei diesem thema auch
jetzt wieder und wieder bundeskanzler
kommuniziert die könnte nicht
unterschiedlicher sein fühlen sie sich
denn mitgenommen von ihm wenn es um das
ganz große thema krieg und frieden die
sicherheitslage in europa geht
ich halte diese diskussion über
kommunikation für falsch menschen sind
unterschiedlich wir arbeiten eng mit
einander ich habe heute aus dem rat
mehrfach mit ihm konferiert dass wir
unsere aussagen miteinander
parallelisieren dass wir unsere
erkenntnisse zusammen legen und die die
bedachtsamkeit entwickelt sich aus den
beiträgen von unterschiedlichen menschen
in unterschiedlichen erfahrungen und
spielen und das ist die stärke dieser
bundesregierung und das ist auch wenn
ich das so sagen darf die stärke des
zusammenspiels von olaf scholz summieren
aber kommunikation ist doch gerade in
solchen zeiten sehr sehr wichtig weil
die menschen einfach wissen wollen was
ihnen bevorsteht was die regierenden
planen gerade in diesen zeiten wie jetzt
wie scholz es also aktuell macht eher
spärlich auftreten bloß nicht aus der
ruhe bringen lassen zumindest öffentlich
aber dann doch eben mal enorme
kurswechsel vollziehen wäre das auch ihr
rat
ich bin hier nicht der pressesprecher
des bundeskanzleramt ist ich bin aber
eng eingebunden in die entscheidung und
finde sie werden gut argumentiert und
dargestellt der vizekanzler robert
habeck herzlichen dank für das gespräch
nach brüssel
vielen dank
und das gespräch haben wir aufgezeichnet
der selbst erklärte ich lasse mich von
vorwürfen nicht beeindrucken
bundeskanzler steht unter druck durch
die weltlage den krieg schlechte
umfragewerte und durch die menschen in
deutschland den einen macht er zuviel
den anderen viel zu wenig heute abend
hieß es im zdf was nun herr scholz
andreas robot und lask
das zdf hauptstadtstudio am frühen abend
der kanzler kommt was nun herr scholz so
heißt das format 25 minuten rede und
antwort die fragen in diesen zeiten
drehen sich ausschließlich um den
ukraine krieg olaf scholz weiß er muss
in die offensive will die vorwürfe
entkräften er zauderer und zögerer vor
allem bei der lieferung von schweren
waffen an die ukraine dh es gibt hier
keine entscheidung die danach gemacht
werden kann wie sie jemand in
irgendeiner pr-abteilung entwerfen mag
immer noch was drauf oder niemals etwas
was sie jetzt zuletzt angesprochen haben
das muss jede einzelne entscheidung
sorgfältig abgewogen werden hat er
scholz verteidigt sein agieren als
besonnen und nicht forschen können das
gilt auch gegenüber den
koalitionspartnern beispiel öl embargo
gegen putin gestern hatte die grüne
außenministerin erklärt das sei in
trockenen tüchern bei olaf scholz klingt
das heute ganz anders
können allmählich aus der kohle raus wir
können etwas schneller auf öl verzichten
wir wissen aber um die noch ungelösten
probleme die es bei raffinerien im osten
deutschlands gebe und die sind auch noch
nicht gelöst gelöst ist für die
opposition so einiges nicht in köln
treffen sich cdu und csu zur gemeinsamen
präsidiumssitzung eigentlich geht es um
das thema innere sicherheit in knapp
zwei wochen wird in nrw gewählt da heißt
es stimmung machen um stimmen zu
gewinnen es auch und gerade gegen den
kampf waren die kommunikation bei diesem
wichtigen thema ist über wochen
mangelhaft ein bundeskanzler muss den
menschen in so einer schlimmen situation
über sie haben mehr
orientierung geben wenn am ende nur
anton hofreiter der taktgeber der
deutschen politik ist dann zeigt sich
schon daran dass da was nicht stimmt
zeigen und stimme ich auch dass der
bundeskanzler bislang nicht in die
ukraine gereist ist finden sie bei der
union deshalb macht sich jetzt friedrich
merz auf den weg nach kiew als einer
frau gegen den kanzler soll das nicht
verstanden
habe es dem bundeskanzler empfohlen
selbst zu reisen die letzten zwei monate
hat er das nicht getan
es gibt aus meiner sicht keine
veranlassung jetzt irgendwo darauf zu
warten dass ein mitglied der
bundesregierung eine reise plant wenn
ich eingeladen werde entscheide ich
selbst ob ich reise oder nicht und ich
frage auch nicht um genehmigung und
warum olaf scholz nicht nach kiew reist
dass diese gründet er erstmals
ausführlich im zdf intendant das ist
doch immerhin ein ganz bemerkenswerter
vorgang ist dass der präsident der
bundesrepublik deutschland damit eine
mehrheit wie glaube ich niemand vor ihm
in der bundesversammlung wenige wochen
vorher für eine zweite amtszeit
nominiert worden ist ausgeladen worden
ist das steht dem immer noch entgegen da
sind der sache das steht der sache im
weg olaf scholz will raus aus der
defensive sucht die öffentlichkeit das
interview sendet deutliche signale in
die eigenen reihen an die opposition und
auch in richtung ukrainische regierung
und das komplette interview mit dem
bundeskanzler noch mal zum nachkochen
auf zdf heute und in der zdf mediathek
so und hanna hat jetzt hier die
übersicht was heute auch noch wichtig
ist die bundesregierung ist überzeugt
dass die ausbildung ukrainischer
soldaten an westlichen waffen keinen
direkten kriegseintritt bedeutet das
sagte regierungssprecher hebestreit und
widersprach damit einem gutachten des
wissenschaftlichen dienstes des
bundestags in dem gutachten heißt es man
würde den gesicherten bereich der nicht-
kriegsführung verlassen wenn es um die
ausbildung an solchen waffen ging
in berlin hat bundespräsident steinmeier
heute georgiens staatspräsident in
surabischwili empfangen bei den
gesprächen ging es vor allem um
unterstützung für das land am schwarzen
meer dessen wunsch nach einer eu
mitgliedschaft aktuell noch dringlicher
ist im heute-journal update äußerte
präsidentin surabischwili die hoffnung
dass es angesichts des russischen
angriffs auf die ukraine eine schnelle
entscheidung über eine aufnahme
georgiens in diäten giesen wohl politik
und das ganze interview gibt es um 23 45
hier im zdf und jetzt schon in der
mediathek
mit einem nazi-vergleich hat russlands
außenminister lawrow auf international
für empörung gesorgt darauf hatte in
bezug auf den ukrainischen präsidenten
sie lenski gesagt das zitat die
eifrigsten antisemiten in der regel
juden seien und behauptet auch hitler
habe jüdisches blut gehabt die
israelische regierung verlangte eine
entschuldigung und bestellte den
russischen botschafter ein buntes
innenministerin feser bezeichnete die
aussage love rocks gegenüber der funke
mediengruppe als unerträglich
die von der gewerkschaft verdi
angekündigte warnstreik woche für
beschäftigte im sozial- und
erziehungsberufen hat begonnen den
anfang machten heute mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter der sozialarbeit wie
hier in hannover verdi will so den druck
in den laufenden tarifverhandlungen
erhöhen fordert werden mehr lohn und
bessere arbeitsbedingungen
am mittwoch bleiben dann kitas und
schulischen ganztagsangebote beschlossen
das brot für die welt wird knapp auch
das ist eine folge des kriegs die
kornkammer europas das ist nicht einfach
nur ein schlagwort das ist realität und
das sind massive sorgen die ukraine
braucht ihre landwirtschaft und die welt
braucht die ukraine allein dort gibt es
etwa ein viertel so viele
landwirtschaftliche flächen wie in allen
eu staaten zusammen
sonnenblumen weizen gerste überall zählt
das land zu den top produzenten und top
exporteuren und jetzt was das heißt
bauer im krieg zu sein mit feldern nicht
weit entfernt von der front hat dara
hassanzadeh miterlebt
so arbeiten wir jetzt
bauer wieder lieben macht sich bereit
zum arbeitseinsatz auf dem feld es muss
bestellt werden die nächste russische
stellung ist nur 30 kilometer entfernt
wir haben hart gummimatten in der kabine
befestigt das glas markt brechen aber
der fahrer ist gegen kleine schreibt
geschützt so einfach ist das so macht
man das auf dem dorf
2000 hektar land bearbeitet sein betrieb
300 hektar davon sind im moment heiße
kampfzone unzugänglich völlig zerbombt
doch auch auf den anderen feldern landen
geschosse hinterm hof hat vitali
gestapelt was er seit kriegsbeginn
eingesammelt hat unsere russischen
freunde wie sie es nennen
zeige euch wie wir raketen von unseren
feldern holen nur die die nicht mehr
gefährlich sind und von minensuchen
entschärft worden sind
aber so ein bisschen sind wir auch nur
ein
vitali belastet nicht nur die ständige
gefahr für sich und das leben seiner 15
arbeiter er hat millionen von redner in
maschinen saatgut und dünger investiert
doch die export händler werden seine
linsen und sonnenblumen diesmal nicht
kaufen weil sie es nicht weiterverkaufen
können wegen der russischen seeblockade
gegen ukrainische helfen
die agrarhändler sind aus dem geschäft
und der lokale markt hier im raum
sabrina ist zu klein wir müssen unsere
erzeugnisse in die zentrale oder west
ukraine transportieren aber das ist
logistisch unrentabel
dazu kommt sollte die russische armee
hier weitere geländegewinne erzielen
dann wäre es sein land es wäre ein
totalverlust der ernte
unserer armee muss diesem russischen
abschaum in den hintern treten
30 40 von unserem land haben sie besetzt
darunter die fruchtbarsten böden der
region satirischer und carson das wird
sich landesweit auf unsere erntemengen
auswerten
ich weiß nicht wer dort ernten wird
russen oder irgendwer von der krim
seine ernte soll nicht in falsche hände
fallen deshalb hebt vitali auf wunsch
der ukrainischen armee schützengräben
aus in der ukraine kämpfen auch die
bauern um jeden meter land
gerade heute meldet die ukraine wieder
russische angriffe und wieder auch auf
ein großes getreidelager im südosten des
landes haben russische soldaten laut
einem cnn-bericht einen handel für
landmaschinen geplündert und dabei
maschinen und gerät für fast fünf
millionen euro abtransportiert
die mähdrescher allerdings seien jetzt
erst mal nicht zu nutzen die russischen
soldaten hatten offenbar nicht damit
gerechnet dass sie mit gps tracker
ausgestattet sind und die beute mit
einer software aus der ferne gesperrt
werden kann
wir haben in dieser sendung schon über
die bemühungen der europäer gesprochen
ein weiteres sanktionspaket gegen
russland auf den weg zu bringen wichtig
dabei ist dass niemand ausschert nicht
in europa aber eben möglichst auch sonst
niemand auf der welt und da wird's
kompliziert indien etwa hat 1,4
milliarden einwohner viel militärgerät
aus russland und sieht auch sonst die
chance auf schnäppchen bei energie aus
russland indiens premier ist heute in
berlin die chance irritationen
auszuräumen andreas künast
auf diesen besuch hat nicht nur
deutschland gewartet auf diesen gast
wartet die halbe welt es ist das erste
mal in diesem jahr dass der mächtigste
mann indiens indien verlässt das erste
mal dass bundeskanzler scholz persönlich
fragen kann was berlin aber auch paris
london washington brennend interessiert
ministerpräsident modi auf welcher seite
der geschichte wollen sie stehen indien
die regierung modi hat russlands über
verlauf die ukraine nicht verurteilt hat
die sanktionen nicht unterstützt hat
sich im un sicherheitsrat enthalten
das modi nach dem massaker von butscher
erstmals eine internationale
untersuchung verlangte ist das einzige
entgegenkommen auf dem scholz aufbauen
kann es ist sicherlich ein
entgegenkommen indiens aber eben nur ein
sehr geringes denn man weiß natürlich
dass man sich nicht leisten kann
russland hier zu kritisieren indien ist
sicherheitspolitisch von russland
abhängig wirtschaftlich aber vom westen
das ist für die indische außenpolitik
natürlich ein großes dilemma es ist
nicht nur die regierung auch in teilen
von indiens riesiger bevölkerung ist
russland populär anti westliche
propaganda weit verbreitet russland
geschäftspartner waffenbruder freund
scholz gibt sich mühe schleppt modi auf
den kanzleramts balkon sagt
zusammenarbeit beim klimaschutz zu aber
der unterschied bleibt für den indoor
wird diesen krieg keine seite gewinnen
für den deutschen darf diesen krieg
russland nicht gewinnen der gemeinsame
nenner
klingt so worum es geht darüber haben
wir beide uns sehr sorgfältig
unterhalten ist dass wir miteinander
eine bessere zukunft erreichen aber eben
nicht indem wir kriege gegeneinander
führen sondern indem wir wirtschaftliche
entwicklung und gemeinsame entwicklung
möglich machen aber auch bei seiner
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung setzt
indien auf beide seiten während die
deutsche regierung öl importe aus
russland reduziert entscheidet die
indische sie zu erhöhen
aufgrund der verwerfungen die der krieg
in der ukraine ausgelöst hat schießen
die preise für energie in astronomische
höhen auch die lebensmittelknappheit
belastet jede familie auf der welt
normalerweise wäre die pressekonferenz
in berlin eine der seltenen
gelegenheiten modi auch kritische
unabgesprochene fragen zu stellen aber
es sind heute keine fragen erlaubt
ein ziemlich großer und ziemlich
fragwürdiger gefallen für den
empfindlichen gast während rameau die
hat viel übung darin das beste aus
beiden welten zu wollen und zu bekommen
auch am ende dieses tages in berlin
scheint der mächtige inder ganz
zufrieden zu sein und
hier macht nochmal an arbeiter und
fahren mit einer nachricht aus der
wirtschaft bei der es sich lohnt noch
mal genauer hinzuschauen es geht um
einen großen vermieter in deutschland
die ablage hob der aktienkurs des
immobilienkonzerns ist heute kräftig
abgerutscht zeitweise um fast 50 prozent
und die gründe dafür valerie haller die
blassen durchaus aufhorchen ja ein grund
ist dass die adler gruppe am samstag auf
den allerletzten drücker ihren
jahresabschluss veröffentlicht hat und
dann noch mit einer bösen überraschung
einem gewaltigen verlust von über einer
milliarde euro doch anleger dürften
darauf nicht allzu viel gegeben haben
denn die wirtschaftsprüfer von kpmg
weigern sich die bilanz abzusegnen eine
seltenheit bei einem unternehmen dieser
größenordnung begründung wichtige
informationen seien nicht zugänglich
gemacht worden darunter offenbar und
tausende von e mails da bahnt sich
möglicherweise ein neuer bilanzskandal
an ein schock für anleger die aktie
beendete den tag mit 29 prozent - die
adler group ist in der öffentlichkeit
kaum bekannt gehört aber zu den großen
vermietern deutschlands mit rund 50.000
wohnungen in berlin und düsseldorf und
mieteinnahmen von 342 millionen euro
vergangenes jahr rechtlicher sitz im
steuergünstigen luxemburg ernüchternd an
dem fall ist dass nicht die
wirtschaftsprüfer den stein ins rollen
gebracht haben sondern wieder ein
externer kritiker der auch schon beim
aufdecken des wirecard skandals eine
entscheidende rolle gespielt hat der
hedgefonds-manager fraser wirft adler
bilanzbetrug vor unter anderem seien die
immobilien überbewertet wieder einmal
fragt man sich ob die prüfer nicht schon
viel früher diesen zweifeln hätten
nachgehen müssen vielen dank valerie
nach frankfurt
nach vorläufigen ermittlungen der eu
kommission verstößt apple gegen
europäische wettbewerbsvorschriften
konkret geht es dabei um mobile
bezahldienste die eu-kommission wirft
dem us-konzern vor dass nutzer von
iphones beim kontaktlosen bezahlen
praktisch nur apple benutzen können
nicht aber die angebote anderer anbieter
es gebe anhaltspunkte dass der us
konzern den zugang dritter zu
schlüsseltechnologien beschränkt habe
sollten sich die vorwürfe erhärten droht
apple eine hohe kartellstrafe
für musliminnen und muslime weltweit
geht heute der fastenmonat ramadan zu
ende in jerusalem versammelten sich
zehntausende gläubige vor der al aksa
moschee zum gebet anschluss gab es
geschenke und süßigkeiten für kinder und
auch auf den straßen von indonesiens
hauptstadt jakarta kamen zehntausende
menschen zusammen um feierlich das ende
des ramadan zu begehen
mubarak das war unsere welt an diesem
montag vielen dank dass sie dabei war
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen
abend und empfehlen ihnen das heute
journal update mit nazan götter mir
gegen 23 uhr 45
[Musik]
schon gut und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter die extreme hitzewelle in indien
und pakistan hält weiterhin an hat jetzt
eine kleine delle bekommen aber für
nächste woche werden temperaturen von
über 50 grad tagsüber erreicht werden so
die aktuelle vorhersage in den nächten
sinken die werte kaum unter die 30 grad
marke also große extreme hitze dort
schauen auf das wetter in deutschland
und da haben wir es mit dieser kaltfront
zu tun die bringt etwas regen und
hauptsächlich ganz im norden abkühlung
sonst wird es durchaus warm und schauer
und gewitter sind mit dabei erst einmal
der blick in die nacht im süden lassen
die schauer nach in den frühstunden
komme aber neue wolken auf mit der
kaltfront und dann regnet es durchaus in
gewässernähe bildet sich nebel
temperaturspanne 1 bis 9 grad morgen am
vormittag im norden kompakte wolken mit
regen die ziehen allmählich richtung
osten ansonsten aber sonnige abschnitte
nach südosten hin ist es durchaus auch
mal dichter bewölkt zum nachmittag dort
dann schauer und gewitter hier brodelt
es dann ist kein starkregen geben und
die gewitter können durchaus auch weiter
nach norden im raus wachsen ansonsten
aber trockenes wetter die höchsten
temperaturen liegen bei 12 bis 14 grad
an den küsten und 20 bis 21 grad nach
südwesten hin schauer und gewitter
bleiben auch in den nächsten tagen
programm temperaturen liegen dann bei 12
bis 22 grad ein schöner ab